good morning Millennials MJ it's in so
long since we said that and I'm feeling
very grateful excited and humbled to be
back I'm actually really excited to be
back and to stay back and to not trap
for people who don't like to travel
we've been traveling quite a bit and I'm
so happy to announce that I have no
plans coming up and I'm just gonna be
here in this chair starting my wedding
diet everything is like so far tuned in
a mean like oh yeah I just can't believe
that there's like not a better way to
travel than flying yes and no but then
when we went to Nashville we were
talking about how the flight was so easy
and it's crazy how you just like step on
the plane and you step out in a whole
different land yes we did
you have true amnesia you're like it's
transportation I've never said that yes
we did we said we were saying that
flight to Nashville was pretty easy
which it when did we say that because I
didn't feel that way you didn't feel
that way
it was like an hour and a half and we
said it we said and by the way I trust
my memory more than I trust you know but
like usually something like rings a bell
I'm like I don't even feel that way so I
don't know say said it I think maybe
while you were getting ready for your
show I was like this life here was
really easy and I was and you were like
yes mine too and I was like it's so
crazy how like you could just step on
the plane you're like yeah and you step
out in your somewhere else
never ever we actually completed each
other sandwiches on that one
never said it I don't feel that way okay
you guys I just want there's the proof
is in the pudding you will need to go to
brain camp you said it yourself for sure
you have short-term but memory loss
usually I would agree with you but what
you're saying that I said I don't even
myself agree with so I would never say
that well maybe you weren't listening
when I was talking that or just yes man
that's however you completed my sentence
which makes me think maybe I just know
you that well maybe maybe like you've
had such a treacherous week that you
can't remember when you once felt
positively about the flight that's
possible too I'm just like I'm in the
worst mood these days and I don't know
what to do about it
well pray for us yeah what what do you
do about being abandoned well first
sleep first you have to identify the
source of the bad news it's always
exhaust you have to retrace your pit you
know the pit look for me like thank god
I don't like anymore have like big
problems in my life it's just like I'm
tired I'm annoying I'm done
come with you now I'm gonna get a big
problem because I asked for it um I'm
just like it's exhaustion it's like I
always have to clean my own house and
like I know that if I lived by myself I
would never have to clean my house but
like literally I was up all night doing
dishes last night like Ben wants to pick
you to make dinner and like that's cute
but like do the dishes so it sounds like
Ben is the source he's the source of a
lot of it but he's also a lot of the
source of likely joy great like he made
me dinner last night like I mean like I
got off the red-eye and I was so tired I
slept the whole day and then I woke up
and like there was dinner and like that
never happens and that was great what
was for dinner chicken rocks like my
favorite rice and it was so good but
dishes are not great and Ben knows how
to make make like I mix extra dishes
like god forbid even for one second he
uses a plastic cup no no not washable
not interested the cookbook according to
bed there needs to be disposable
disposable light Isha's pot some hands
yeah but I think it would melt I think
that's a problem no I don't know someone
needs to go on Shark Tank Shark Tank
actually like really came in clutch
trimming this weekend I went to a
wedding and the ceremony was on grass
and like for the months leading up the
bride was like the ceremony's on grass
like make sure you wear wedges or like a
chunky heel and I just really wanted to
wear he not my granny stiletto and you
would never wear wedges and I don't know
I only own one pair budgets and they're
so specific and to like we said you're a
big galoot
they don't wear wedges Yeah right so I
couldn't go back on what I had today
course not that's a problem with the
choice we just say things and then we
like we can't go back right and we can't
be two-faced like then I remembered I
saw this thing on Shark Tank where you
put these little plastic things on the
edge of your heel so you can walk in the
grass and I remember when they went on
Shark Tank I was like that's not a
company but it is a very valuable
product I don't think they got a deal
but they got a deal for me and then the
person who did my package to send it out
was a toaster so she sent me all these
extras and it was just so a big win
they're called soul mates you guys and
they really helped outdoor weddings are
just honestly like not worth it
there's so much that can go wrong yes
but in like Texas in the summer it's
like they're certainly not gonna rain
right and I had my updo so I was ready
to go yeah do you hear that what
happened to my dress I did you guys 10
minutes before we're supposed to leave
for the wedding I put my dress on like
didn't think twice and like Zach is like
doing the zipper and I'm like [ __ ] it
like I'll do it and then I feel that
it's like gaping like the zippers
when the bottom is open so the zipper
was off the track totally broken and
it's accent oh brother like granted to
the tailor but they were closed so I had
like go through so to go through his
sisters like high school clout her
closet like at home and I wore the dress
that she wore to her high school
graduation in 2010 but here's my thing
no offense but like who do you think you
are only showing up with one dress
option oh my I've never since when do
you bring two dresses oh my god always
things just like fit differently like
you feel differently like okay Marilyn
Monroe showing up with one dress that's
okay I mean from now on I will always
bring two dresses in the hard way that
never even occurred to me like finding
one dress that I like is a win enough I
never even thought to bring doing and
now I will now that I'm in tune
I really had like such a great time at
not in that show and it feels like so
much obviously that comes with about I
had a great time Claudia there is there
was no button of course there's a lot no
I worked hard for the good time that I
had okay you know what I mean yeah here
was the schedule we were I got there
Tuesday morning and did a show Tuesday
night and like honestly I'm just not
that type of person who can like jump
and Bob and like if I have a flight
you're gonna have to buy now or else
you're gonna be in these towns for
forever days I need 24 hours to recover
but I can't Atlanta - and I took go to
the venue at 4:00 and start hair makeup
at 3:30 but legitimately one and a half
hours to lay and I ordered room service
and it was absolutely disgusting but
aside from that would see that probably
the cutest hotel ever that I would 100%
recommend it's called the Noel hotel and
OE lle and I was we were adamant about
double beds cuz like I said Jackie
doesn't sleep in me and I know I said
this on the podcast before but like I
need to say it again like there were two
king beds like I don't know what I I
don't know if anyone else thinks that
that's as crazy as I think it is but
it's truly the craziest thing ever
because that's not even heard up in New
York
no but also like we've also traveled
elsewhere and it's not hurt I know ever
it was incredible and the hotel was like
so boutique but also like large and in
charge the only thing that was lacking
was the room service menu Nashville is
very like artisanal oh my god like the
gift shop oh I can't remember where we
said what's up on the podcast live oh
yeah that like maybe people that weren't
privy to but the hotel was very
artisanal $4 for a coffee that was not
tasty like no sponge that's how I would
sum it up like you can only have stevia
but I really did enjoy the hotel and so
we did the
foreshow at Zanies on Tuesday night
which was a smash success just like
toasters up the wazoo
then we did our live toast show
Wednesday we brought out a special guest
Kaitlyn Bristowe oh no that was 14 I
mean literally okay sorry okay she said
the thing about the plane you guys on
Tuesday I brought out Kaitlyn Bristowe
for my live show she was a special guest
cuz usually been as a part of the act
but when we take it on the road it
doesn't really make sense for him to
come even though he was literally in
Nashville the next day on a bachelor
party and wouldn't hang out with me
I can't Liberto FaceTime to Chris
Harrison on her right off stage and it
was like truly amazing it really was
picked up he did yeah that's crazy and
then we in our toast live show Wednesday
and we were like we were adamant about
having some sort of like after-party
post show soiree cocktail attire and so
we told everyone to me that me I said my
favorite part on Broadway called legends
which I don't even think is the best one
no it's not it wasn't great but actually
works in our favor because it wasn't dad
pact hat but it was packed with toasters
so we got there like 11 the toasters
were insane honestly I've never like
been so like well taken care of in my
life like yeah you want a drink you want
a coke er like literally the amount of
times I was brought just like a good
found eye coke was like oh I had a good
found I cook the whole time and like
they were like what songs you went here
and they would like oh request it and
like a national the thing is it's all
live music so in order to get a song you
want played you have to pay for it
because like everyone's greedy and this
is a capitalistic society that we live
in so toasters were paying for my
lifestyle it was amazing but Claudia you
really need to learn to respect out yes
there was so much toaster drama at this
thing oh we tell you guys the toasters
are incredible like on another like the
toasters turned up like they're what
everyone was turned up there were a few
people that were like turned to - oh I
am we'll talk about that in a minute but
there was this cover bag there was this
cover band playing and like they kept
playing like lame-ass old country music
and when they would play wagon wheel was
like lit is how Rascal Flatts anything
current like the toasters were going
insane and they didn't know obviously
that there was like this legit college
reunion going on at their bar but like
read the crowd like girl we were up in
front like any time they played
something even remotely relevant like we
were screaming yeah Larry's throwing
ourselves at them trying to get on stage
and then they played like some podunk
song and they brought this old
songwriter on
nobody was listening so like just weed
the ground so I'm a bit of front and
like I think they're about to play the
song that I requested I kept requesting
Garth Brooks battlers and I like kept
requesting kept progressing and then I'm
like I know it's gonna happen so I go to
the front and with my drinks I'm like
with my toasters I'm ready to go and
they start playing this old-school Alan
Jackson song and like just know we start
complaining to the Chester next to me
she's like she's like this is the
country music we all grew up listening
to like she was from Alabama or
something
and she was like Claudia like you have
to respect Alan Jackson and I was like I
was like I do but like not right now I
was just so easy was such a weird thing
today and I was like the weekend Cuddy
and I would be talking about be like
Claudia you really need to it was just
respect Alan Jackson at all cause I'm
joking me wrong I do like as an artist
but not in my drunken stupor at 1:00 in
the morning I'm like my bachelorette
party in Nashville just like let me live
it was so bizarre and then also when the
bandleader had no clue what was going on
like and why like oh just the day I
understand like at the bar he usually
plays that like what there's usually 10
people they were legit 500 right and it
was making girls and like all like in a
horde and so Claudia told him you were
like said why'd you tell him to say this
guy was like he wouldn't fart for less
than a dollar yeah you had to pay in
2001 dollars for a song and I was like
listen dude I beat I give him $20 to
play wagon-wheel and that was like the
most anyone had paid him so I was like
listen can you just say on the Micra
welcome to the toast and he was like
what we'll do the toast and again he
said it like everyone gonna crowd who I
am then today he thought he was like
invented something new and he was like
dude are you kidding
he's a broad but a really good one but
he made our night that was so much fun
and then we spent the next two days
actually Mayfest targe Ville Central but
so fulfilling
oh my god so all the music Hartsville so
touchable is your favorite performer
honestly wow this is hard okay day one
my favorite performer was probably
damaged I know I don't want specifics I
just want number one it's hard and they
were so many different values but
honestly like Gavin
and I was so excited to see him and
because also the vibe at his concert was
so good like Nissan Stadium every
performance was amazing but like we were
sorry in our box and so it's just so let
me work just a little um you know we
weren't in it Gavin DeGraw I was in yeah
but um I would say my favorite performer
not that you asked or anything was a
three-way tie and I'm not allowed to say
day one day two no between Dan and Shay
they were so they were amazing and like
the good and the bad thing about CMA
fest is that every performer only plays
five songs so if you don't know who the
performer is it's like you don't just
sit through a two-hour set of like songs
you don't know but also if you really
like the performer it's like not enough
but dan + Shay chose the five songs that
I would have wanted that visiting I
would have loved for them to sing them
one of the new one alone together or lay
it all to myself better but yeah um
she's definitely not speechless um but
they did they did well nonetheless I
absolutely loved write young love he
also played the fight songs I would want
him to hear he's truly the hottest man
alive oh I'm sorry the performance of
the festival goes to Luke Holmes
okay that was gonna make their talented
man in country music most talented man
in country music and here's why he
played five songs I would say a new
maybe two or three and I couldn't have
loved more than other two and I couldn't
find them on Spotify the one about a
beer can doesn't break your heart I
couldn't find it and then the other one
about like shots of whiskey
I was literally and Spotify like in the
airport like trying to find it I've
gotta find them and I just want to say
something controversial
he thought he is in a very
unconventional way he thought ya know in
a very like us way and he was just like
holding his drink and you know he had
like dip in and he was just like he
wasn't trying at all and he has
literally the most incredible voice and
I'm like at one point he really wasn't
trying and on his last note of his last
song he just like kept dragging out the
note and like hitting different notes on
his way out and like it was so not plan
he just like was [ __ ] around because
he could the whole was on its a toaster
okay so that was the other part of it
his girlfriend's a toaster her name is
Nicole Sarah
something regular and now I just feel so
much closer to him and like I need to
get more involved right I say might be
like we should triple date well with
quadruple date because also
what's his name um mr. Kelly with the
cat 1/2 of Florida Georgia line with the
last name Kelly is it Richard no I think
it's Brian yes Brian yeah Brian Kelly
1/2 of Florida Georgia line the one who
really you know writes music and plays
his songs but doesn't actually sing his
wife Brittany do me on Instagram like me
and Jackie were like lamenting about the
fact that we were missing two days have
cma fest and we weren't gonna go
the only people I haven't seen that I
really liked wasn't upset about missing
but Keith Urban and Florida Georgia line
and she jamming she was a car you gonna
be at the stadium on Sunday and I was
like oh my god kill me now no I'm not
then she invited me to show in there in
New York so I delayed gratification yeah
but it'll it'll come and venting well we
weren't jogging we were truly the chest
of the town we were the toasted like we
were just like totally in our element
except for the heat I couldn't [ __ ]
stand it but we did our best also like I
checked all of our steps and we walked
more than 10,000 steps every day that
does with guys me it felt like 100,000
steps
yeah it really did and I can't believe
we like didn't get hung over that was
the miracle all weekend like I'm
straight then we were drinking all day I
was trying to be like measured about my
drinking and then like we also stayed up
walking sex in the city so that we
wouldn't fall asleep I mean we could
sing literally the most disgusting food
I ate a fish fillet from McDonald and I
was so girls I didn't finish it I can't
believe what it is it's like a fried
fish and then like a piece of American
cheese it was not good and tartar sauce
it was not good and they would've eaten
anything and I didn't eat that but we
haven't made for a price well we were
fine things could be worse but now that
we're done with our recap a more
unlimited amount of time here are the
best five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so much has
happened I think we have more than we
have more than five and they're not
gonna be fast but nevertheless first up
we just have to talk about ariana grande
and Pete Davidson are engaged after
dating for a few weeks reports People
magazine okay so like this is so crazy
uh-huh and I'm worried about them I just
wanted to put it out there in a
concerning loving friendly way I'm
worried about them really yes well you
either have to be like worried about
them or like be just completely like
naive and believe that they're like in
love in a month and they're meant to be
and when they're live happily ever after
definitely
people who like fall in love in two
weeks and get married and have been
married for 90 years
it's so rare and it's definitely
possible I just I don't feel that vibe
for them I mean I don't know them and
it's like I either have to feel that buy
for them or I'm immensely concerned and
I'm on the fence where I'm feeling like
I want to reach out and help but they
don't know who I am right I I'm also
like happy for them because like love is
a beautiful thing and engagements are
beautiful thing but it's it's weird
cause like with celebrities it's like I
don't equate engagement with wedding
it's like oh where did she get engaged
yeah and like I don't see these two
having a wedding success rate of
engagements is like 30% right I don't
know it's it's very strange it's just so
crazy how like they're so in the news
right now like everyone is talking about
this I know and like he's gonna like
okay I had so many thoughts about him
this morning as I was getting ready cuz
like obviously he comes from SNL and he
really truly works one hour a week yeah
no he's like in one sketch a week so he
really works like cuz he's in a minute
but he does a lot of stand-up like she
does yeah okay
so that makes me feel better can you
open the Dave Chappelle which is a real
Colin Jost super prestigious that's
that's prestigious but as far as SNL
goes like right now he's not working
right there all right
yeah until like November this show
sounds like a dream job no I know
no no you should parlay you're coming
into SNL no and I think that's like the
dream for all Cummings
yeah and like not only do you only have
to work one night a week
yes it's Saturday night but there's like
a bomb after party afterwards where you
can meet Ariana Grande and get engaged
true so true
I think that's then you know what I
wouldn't even want to be honest and I
would just like want to be in the end
where they'll clap you know that's like
I would be good at that I'd be like
right in trying to be like yeah like
that's so Titus I still have one more
episode of Kimmy Schmidt and I'm like
savoring it kind of want it to be over
but also like because I don't want
there's more coming first of all we have
six more episodes second of why did they
do it like let's talk about the
disappointment that is season four of
Kimmy Schmidt let's talk about it's so
disappointing that I actually don't
remember what's happening except for
Kobe only got six episodes and one of
them was actually torturous torture
third of all there's like not enough
Titus like Titus thinks is truly his own
show and like the funny thing about
Kimmy Schmidt is that it was before the
season like one of the greatest shows of
all time aside from the fact that Kimmy
is worse like she's the main character
the show was literally named after her
and I can't
standard you know who I can't stand yes
the the landlord right I can't stand her
hug lady she is the drama teacher from
confession shop me like so house was
hilarious though and giving that her
ashes as cocaine that was me she's the
drama teacher I know and you know what
how the mighty have fallen
Chuck is all I'm gonna say I mean my
favorite is Jacqueline my favorite is
tightest like honestly I feel like in
some ways I am treated I feel like in
some ways I am Jacqueline me too
but here's the thing but I'm when it
comes to Titus and I'm also kidding it's
so sad don't say that about yourself
isn't that sad when it comes to Titus
it's truly unbelievable how like every
word he's every line he has is could win
in any like yeah and for everything that
comes out of his mouth is absolutely
hysterical where it's like some shows
even if it's like the funniest show
you've ever seen like not every line is
hilarious like there's like you know
slows down time everything Titus says
makes me laugh and it's partly because
the writing is so good but also because
he is so funny yeah I like delivering
the line but like then I get like a
tight ass I Spit knowing that like he
doesn't like doesn't lean into the real
Titus doesn't like the fake tighter hmm
but like here's the thing I don't care
cuz we'll have we'll always have
tightness also the the whole thing with
like the Beauty and the Beast the school
play and I'm selling it it's like a
experiential theater like it's relative
focal area and so on point like that
does happen yeah like you go to like a
like an installation it's like in a
school right also I don't know how we
got from call it to Fort Collins SNL and
to Kimmy Schmidt but happy to be here
yes Lee totally I don't have any more
thoughts about Pete Davidson and Arianna
Gani like I'm just like kind of sitting
back watching grabbing popcorn like yeah
I'm sure more news will come out about
them tomorrow that she's like pregnant
or something I kind of wanted to work
out just so they can prove everyone
wrong cuz like people are just including
us are like so negative about everything
I really don't feel negatively about
this I just I'm skeptical I'm wary I've
seen too many celebrity relationships
that negatively you put that was this
weird I waited till you finished you
told me that I was allowed to to comment
as long as they waited til you finish
too many celebrity relations
set burn hot and fizzle out quickly yeah
so like there are a lot of celebrities
who aren't cute right now like Joe Jonas
and sophie Turner are they ever gonna
get married after this season in Game of
Thrones finish oh we shall see because
she's so busy and I'm sure like she
wants to close hot chapter like she
needs to be in Sansa mode I'll be super
like curious to see where all the
characters go after the season like
they've all been launched into total
stardom but is it longevity if they
don't have the show you know I think it
just depends on like your managerial
looking like lark obviously she's been
another stuff yeah I think it depends on
like what you want I feel like a lot of
those actors like just want to be in
artisanal films yeah and like they
thought like Game of Thrones would be
like super like artisanal basically yeah
and short for independence and so now
that they're like Big Time magazine
editors like I just don't know if
they're that's what they signed up for
yeah no they're they're leading a life
of regret and also this is really
underrated but Sansa Stark did a movie
like a girly action movie with Hailee
Steinfeld where they both were in like
the CIA it was stretchy DVD of course
but I watched it because dub Cameron was
in and I just searched for Def Con and
watch everything she's in and it's like
pretty good but it's like I don't see
her in that beat either yeah so it's
confusing I feel like she I don't know
it'll be really cool to watch it will be
what's our next show we'll the last game
of Thrones yes in more engagement news
Vanderpump world stars Jax and Brittany
are engaged I can't believe that we have
another show since then and we never
spoke about her being is so nice and so
pretty and she put up an Instagram where
she looked gorgeous video video yeah oh
my god who is that she looks
unbelievable unbelievable so excited for
the season of pomp Royals because now
that I read a blind item that wasn't
100% about them but it could have been
I'm and it wasn't from it wasn't from
empty though yeah it was from Hollywood
gossip calm which is legit a katuk
Bernardo not it right and I'm just I'm
choosing to be so happy for them in this
picture of her ring with him in the
background like he looks so happy so
happy and you know that she's so happy
and like she really did change him see
like I said they proved everyone wrong
and like I feel so good and I don't know
I'm just like a Jax stand and like
literally do anything on the show and I
wouldn't mind because like hey I think
he knows what he's doing like he knows
that this show has an expiration date
he's trying to make it last as long as
possible and if he has to sleep with
face to do that then that's what he has
to do and it's completely fine and every
time we see him he literally could not
be more nice more genuine like remember
he was like how are you listen how's
your husband like he's never even met
been like he's literally the nicest guy
ever so I agree with anything bad anyone
says about him also I know I've
mentioned this before but if you want to
like understand him a little bit more
and you'll start to see that kind of
like seeing that he knows what he's
doing for TV read the article that
complex get on him it was like an it was
the future it was um a full a full page
spread and it was a few years ago go
read it and you might understand a
little bit more about like why he does
the things that he does on the show also
speaking of bender from roles I went to
pump over the weekend because I was in
LA for pride and pump is like right in
it she chose an amazing location like
West Hollywood there at whole Santa
Monica Boulevard it's like gay bars gay
clubs and where the actual parade slash
concert is held where Kim Petrus
performed Kim Petrus responded to me on
DMS she Lisa has an amazing spot and it
was so popular and literally like they
wouldn't let it was bopping like we
could knock in a table and then
obviously the guy that I was with knew
one of the waiters so they let us sit
down I mean I was so hungry the food was
honestly horrible but it was it's like a
real restaurant you don't expect it to
like new and it's like beautiful I have
like waiters and like the food came like
I was just looking out expecting like
drinks to come do you know what I mean
yeah no I feel like only drinks come
yeah and the I've been there before I
remember we went to Scott Ian yeah he
sat down for 30 minutes I'm like no
drinks ever came no but then we also
went and we got that like huge table
that was like three circular tables
pushed together which me that would
happen at home yeah so we also like ate
like kings and had the greatest time and
had like watermelon pump-tini oh yeah
so it was just like it's really a
cultural experience and basically about
sir I got to pump sorry I got to pump
literally the cast had just thought they
all filmed a big meal there obviously
she and I was still like thirsting
around looking for people to notice her
what did you just ask me no sir
I said sir so the next day that was
Saturday the rain is Sunday but it's
like a whole weekend affair so Saturday
I went to like this big gay birthday
party and like everyone was so skinny it
was unbelievable like no one
a shirt like I'm literally I never get
into here like I felt insecure from
these like really really like built guys
and then we went to prom afterwards and
then Sunday is the day so before the
before the parade you're like supposed
to go to brunch so I'm like pregame and
stuff so we made a reservation at Sur to
pregame and that's where all the staff
was working but I was so unbelievably
hungover I didn't wake up till noon so I
miss brunch what time was your brunch
for noon that's early look people in LA
like wake up at 6:00 am that's crazy
it's so we can never move there okay you
still feel like we can move to Nashville
no and no income tax no I know so when
we got there we were like gung-ho on
moving there because our uber driver
told us that like a thousand Millennials
move to the gulch a week and that
there's no income tax so I was like okay
Millennials tax I'm down but just after
spending time there any old
it's literally like moving to Vegas for
me it would be too much yeah and also
like we kept saying this we ate so much
in Nashville but like we didn't have one
good meal no and like I kept I was
getting like so hung like hungover and
tired because I was never eating like
substantial food like grilled chicken
like I was literally eating just like
fries and croissants the whole time
totally and there's someone who's like
kosher there's absolutely nothing so you
have to eat there and I ate terribly but
I also made so much and it was just hard
to get a good meal for us okay so
congrats to Whitney and Jeff Congrats
abrini and jest and I'm so here for it I
hope that they turn around season seven
faster usually it's in November like I
need September make it happen I need to
see Lala's brown her I need to see that
I was got hair she's not into it she's
more no but she's she's evolving which I
like you can't like try me the same
person Brad I agree their next story
actually but you know who was the same
person forever and the look works for
her Vince Vaughn Quincy took Kristin
Dodie
she looks exactly the same as she did
yeah like she doesn't she's just like
that's how she wakes up in the you know
anything like she doesn't have to do
anything no it's it's honestly must be
nice a hundred percent okay next story
Vince Vaughn was arrested for a DUI
mugshot revealed he looks very happy
yeah he was smiling in it honestly he's
like top five treatment for me I know I
know I feel sad about it cuz I think
he's really hot I mean he's like such a
nice life or so I thought and honestly
like when people get arrested like it's
not my business like if you want if you
get arrested for like smoking pot like
that's your business I couldn't care
less but if you get arrested for a G
I like and you're like you could have
heard other people like then I'm Maddie
that's not cool that's not cool like
that's where I draw the line like when
people like getting like trouble and
like they have to apologize it's like
you don't apologize it's none of my
business what you do in your own time
but if you get in the car drunk and like
you could put yourself and others at
risk like then I mad at you just like
I'm a little upset with it's on for this
meteo and if you just got arrested for
like bianco public intoxication like
that's your business it's not like you
know what I'm saying I agree I don't
care I don't expect an apology like I
expected an apology now like this is
uncool this is uncool I just want him to
like be happy
hi Stephanie he says he's in your tub
tree men you need new dream man Claude
okay
[ __ ] you [ __ ] like he's mine please and
no he's everyone's dream man okay here's
my dream man top five Vince Vaughn not
number one in no particular order
okay Brett Aldridge John Mayer Vince
Vaughn Jason Segel I think it's gonna
say that and like who's another tall
chubby man I may forget anyone that I
always talk about then sure
okay here's my house top five is a lot
Sam hunt good one yeah um like Zac Efron
what I love his personality
okay and then I love that he leans into
his musical um he would like sing to me
palace totally I'm just here for it
honestly Vince Vaughn Jason Segel has
always been like my dream man yeah I
still like love Nick Jonas I don't know
why I can't get over him you like short
men oh and Chris Pratt but like now he's
too hung and he's a dick yeah yeah and
he's so rude
and also miles tellers in mine Oh
totally but now like that's weird cuz I
know his fiancee and like she's a big
toaster and she said we're like her
family so like I guess she don't do that
to family you don't and then the worst
up Mason Ramsay you guys Mason Ramsay
perform twice I can't believe we didn't
mention that we saw him perform the
national anthem which I don't want to be
rude or anything but he absolutely stunk
it's a difficult song to sing I'm not
gonna lie and he was there was the most
people he's probably ever sing in front
of because he was out there arena and
like um I feel bad for him but like he
was terrible
but then we saw him resign first that
whole Reznik concert at Blake Shelton
sorry but no that's Dierks Bentley's bar
darhk's yeah he said
like a medley of show tunes and it was
wonderful and we were right in front and
like we were literally screaming at the
top of our lungs and honestly the way we
got there was so interesting we left in
the Sun say damn on Thursday night and
the uber pickup zone area was next level
torture and we're sitting down like our
ears legit 30 minutes away and these two
girls come up and they're like toasters
and we're like hey and then they're
troopers like right on the corner and
she's like she wants to drop you off and
like now that I think about it we should
have got into a car were strangers but
like whatever it's not you literally get
kidnapped by uber and so we got in the
car with these two girls and they both
work for like song writers and they're
like big in Nashville and they like told
us about him the guy was on the list and
it was so nice like they legit like
don't know what's from [ __ ] and they
like couldn't have been nicer to us
totally except that they got us on the
list that didn't exist and we walked
right into the bar which we could have
done nobody walked in with purpose
because we had a company name right but
that's the key the key of life guys is
to an Adele V your way through
everything like that was my we were mono
fired
so we got so far because this because an
Adele eightwest O'Brien there's like so
many events and different bars and
different parties that you have to be in
the list for you have to have a ticket
for like obviously we planned this trip
like a week ago we didn't have anything
with us so we were just walking into
places with purpose like pretending like
we needed to be there and people were
like buying it yeah and we had a few
things on our side like we had media
passes and whatnot and the good people
at CMA we're so good to us but it's all
about pretending like you know where
you're going and just walking even if
you're walking into a brick wall like
walk with purpose
and no one will question you know
especially not at CMA fest also someone
told me Google Vince Vaughn's thumb ooh
let me see
it doesn't look okay I guess he has like
a small I don't know honestly
disappointing yeah okay well he got it
to you I I'll be expecting a an apology
sometime soon and I look forward to it
and we saw Mason MC perform and he he is
being protected by his guitar player who
like couldn't stop smiling I'm so happy
to like be performing with this legend
and also it was so interesting to people
in the audience because it was a lot of
much older people who would probably
like loved Hank Williams but then also
like big rednecks who would like crunch
like a beer can on their head and like
this guy in front of me was probably 300
pounds but like so trim and he was
six feet tall and he was like wearing a
muscle tank and they've never seen
anyone dance like that in my life like
it's just nice in Ramsey bringing
different people from different worlds
together and he truly is a town but he
still does need our protection is what I
learned because like he's definitely
very overwhelmed and he needs protection
mm-hmm for sure so we're doing a great
job guys keep up the good work
yeah next up in more fake news I don't
know why they're pushing this their
agenda on us Nick Jonas brings Priyanka
Chopra to meet his family at his
cousin's wedding in Atlantic City I just
look they could literally start having
sex in front of me and I wouldn't buy it
100% they could literally get married
and have a 60-year marriage where
they're completely in love and I still
wanna buy it I know I said they just
wouldn't be completely just like stop I
don't know what they both are trying to
cover up by dating each other but
whatever it is I'm gonna ask empty
because I'm not [ __ ] buying it I've
I've heard by the way we need lists of
things to ask any Priyanka Chopra and
Nick Jonas Nick Jonas no there's so much
to ask it oh Anthony Bourdain yeah Kate
Spade yeah
Brittany Murphy Brittany Murphy um
avicii avicii but here's the thing you
guys mean Jackie were just talking about
how we're that kind of retexe like all
these people who are like doubters and
unbelievers of like the Hollywood
[ __ ] like keep dying and we just
want you to know that if anything
happens to us god forbid a million times
not go ahead like it's because we spoke
out about this and like don't look I
feel at the studio could be played like
at my funeral here you know I'm really
getting nervous I soon it's not because
we wanted it or it's not because of an
accent like it's because someone was
trying to kill us like don't let that
we're gonna be mark sailing except we're
not child predators oh we're talking
about mark sailing too and the whole
glee circle I like even got so nervous I
commented something on enews his
instrument last night and I tagged you
and it was like something like bringing
hi Michele oh yeah you bet happily
didn't even see exactly I did he did it
three seconds later because I was so
nervous people working with like come
after me like and he has the blood like
the privilege to be anonymous Blake
we're out there putting our lives at
risk
yeah so that Harvey boxing I was killed
yeah oh my god I'm so nervous now and
like but we're gonna do it for you guys
but I'm so scared oh man and she's
already tomorrow and it realized yeah
Wednesday I hipping it's Monday cuz it's
like the first day we're back right but
no it's a four-day work week gonna be a
lot of five day work weeks you guys
anyways here are the deeds that are fake
obviously whatever Nick Jonas is going
with priyanka chopra appears to be the
real deal because she was his date for a
wedding and not just any wedding it was
a family affair that's like so [ __ ] up
that he would bring his family into this
farce the youngest jo bro and Priyanka
were arm-in-arm at his cousin's wedding
near Atlantic City over the weekend she
was draped in a gold dress and Nick was
suited and booted but no socks with his
white sneakers so chic maybe she's just
like a wedding crasher you know or she's
trying to hide something in pretentious
and Nick Jonas that's this you know what
she's hiding
no do you yeah say it I can't whisper it
yeah I'll tell you that Texas me right
now I say no no I want to not please
look it's not that it sounds not
salacious so sad no text it I'm scared
text it okay I'll text it everyone
sorry podcasts for the silence you're
gonna need this we also have to talk to
nt about Jamie Lynn Spears and her
daughter huh I know oh and Dan Schneider
and like is The Reckoning ever coming
for dinner for Dan Schneider
oh she texted I texted it to her oh my
god that is not a big deal or you could
actually I said but it's just like
nothing like it should on my place no no
I'm nervous
do your own research okay come relying
on us yeah okay okay what's next I truly
like I can't I know angel or I even
people try to make me feel dumb like I'm
not dumb I know Nick and Priyanka are
not dating
right anymore and if they wanted to both
cover up something they should be dating
more realistic people like Priyanka
Chopra should be dating like an
international cosmopolitan businessman
and a niche ownership we didn't make a
16 year old beauty queen a hundred
percent like Olivia COPO who is back
together with Danny Amendola months
after the split you guys this is just I
think the warnings a spoken about Olivia
culpo and quite some time I know because
she her and Danny broke up three months
ago and I think like she was really
struggling like and she worked so hard
so I feel like she was like always doing
things for work but like personally I
feel like and I also feel like she was
probably really upset because she didn't
know what to do with her big Patriots
about her collection but now she can
still use it so I'm happy for her yeah
but even though well he moved to the
Dolphins and she's still from Rhode
Island the Patriots are hurt they're on
his it's not interesting but they're
completely his no but he's actually not
yeah so they're her so I think she her
sweater collections by the way just
quickly to clarify the panty episode
he's not coming on because he's
anonymous it's gonna be podcast so we're
gonna do our episode tomorrow and I'm
then have a boxed dress
you're welcome yeah okay and it'll
probably be about two hours yeah oh my
god
two hours of pit okay Olivia COPO and
Danny Amendola just can't quit each
other it seems they were spotted back
together over the weekend showing off a
major peed PDA the recently broken up
couple were very much not so at a
friend's wedding Saturday in Houston
where we're told Danny was in the
wedding party sources tell us Olivia
came is Danny's Eve and that they were
hold doing lots of kissing hugging and
hand-holding cute I mean this is just
everything I ever dreamed of I hope this
means that they're back together and
whatever issues that they had like
they've overcome well what is used today
I think what I read was like he wasn't
happy with some of the career choices
that she was making maybe she was like
working a little too hard I also read
that he wasn't pleased with her going
nude in Sports Illustrated oh my god
what a weenie I don't know but that's
also like what I read I also read
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas are
dating right it's just like we're out
here like doing like boots on the ground
work because like we're just being fed
informational lies yeah and it's like
just like an average person who believes
what they read who's just like a totally
naive and I'm so sorry oh no it's like
they don't even know what they think
they know do you know and it's like but
I know what they think they know but
what I really know I mean yeah and then
you read that like nine piece thread on
John Doe and your whole world is shaken
to the core no like when we were in high
school abused olivia really introduced
us to wine and she was obsessed morally
but you're crazy like everything's fine
nobody does drugs everyone loves each
other everyone isn't lying and like the
older we got and like the more you know
realistic me god it's just like it's so
disheartening it's like everything that
I read is it's just fake unless it's
like really factual based like this max
story and also speaking of blind someone
means to talk about Kevin Spacey film is
set for July release after sexual
misconduct claims okay this is so crazy
inside well it's sad for not Kevin
Spacey like the other actors in the film
obviously like it's doomed from the
start
supporters of the times up movement will
not be happy to learn that the time is
up for Kevin Spacey to be stuck in the
dog house billionaire boys club starring
Spacey and Ansel Elgort is finally set
to release on July 19th
two and a half years after filming
wrapped and Spacey is featured in the
trailer just as the producers were about
to make a deal to distribute the movie
last October
he was accused of sexual assault by rent
actor Anthony Rapp then other men came
forward the movie based on a true story
of Los Angeles Ponzi scheme ring in the
1980s also features Emma Roberts Suki
Waterhouse Billie lourd and this Andy
Warhol Cary Elwes business crazy Spacey
was cut from the film all the money in
the world after his scandal and fired
from house of cards
Richard DuPont who plays a drug dealer
in boys club as does twin brother Robert
said it is time for Spacey to reappear
on the big screen no it is not people
have such short memories dupont told me
and Spacey is almost unrecognizable in a
beard and glasses ok that wait sorry I'm
just like I've never experienced like a
full cycle of what happens to a predator
but like don't you like you lose
everything like might go to jail even if
you don't like your life's earned
forever and you just have to like live
off the money that you've been like in
exile do you still make money like
Harvey Weinstein's not gonna like work
again are you um no and like I think
he's going to jail but but why isn't
Kevin Spacey like maybe the statue of
limitation is I'm saying that yeah why
is he back to work well he's not back to
work so he filmed this movie before the
alibis like why should everyone suffer
because he's a [ __ ] predator and it
seems like a legit movie so what they're
just gonna sit on the movie like they
could have reshot it with someone else
just whose scene but that would be like
millions millions of dollars or just put
it out with him and hope for the best
there's really no right answer here
other than don't cast Kevin Spacey in
your movies because everyone in
Hollywood until he was a predator before
all this came out and house of cards
firing him it's like you knew he was a
predator so why fire him now you still
knew he was a predator what's the
difference to you predator predator so I
don't feel sorry for these people me
neither they're all gonna be totally
fine whether or not this movie comes out
and also like you cast him when he was a
predator which way he was predatorial
you know what there's so what you got
was a predator you cast a predator and
you got a front they say what do they
say about like being a dog you play with
the dogs oh wow you roll in the dirt you
know what is here it's like you want to
play dirty get in the mud oh yeah
it's like it's like the equivalent of
like you put a fire you're gonna get
burned yeah but it's like you play with
the dogs you couldn't get dirty maybe
that's it
looks like this is that was like it's
like I get dirty jobs I don't know what
it is
oh you lie with okay you lie with the
dogs you're gonna get fleas yeah thank
you to Elizabeth Brooks Brooke Adam and
Victoria
that's so funny if you lie with the
Predators you're gonna not have your
movie come out and that's except one
male okay someone else wrote a comment
of what they thought it was she's
similar if you let dogs sleep in here
baby oh my god wait also um
you lay down with the dogs you get fleas
play with the dogs you might get please
mess with the bull you get the horns
that too
oh yeah but that's only if you're
hanging out with Leeanne Locken yeah
okay last final story
Kylie Jenner deletes all photos of
stormy Webster's face on Instagram this
story is crazy plus the accompanying
blind item oh did you not see this what
oh my god first let me read the story
Kylie Jenner has deleted all photos of
stormy Webster's face on Instagram
fans notice the reality star removed
pictures so adorable on her on Sunday
the makeup mogul shared a new selfie
showing off her freckles while stormy
face remained hidden from the view quote
I spy with my little eye dot about the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
road actually she's never on the show so
I don't think she's wearing up with the
Kardashians star anymore when an
Instagram user noted that Kylie had cut
her baby out of the new photo the new
mom replied yeah I cut my baby out I'm
not sharing photos on my girl right now
Kylie didn't go to detail about her
reasoning behind the decision the move
may have surprised fans considering
Kylie posted a picture of her holding
her daughter in a Gucci baby carrier
just last week this photo along with a
few other shots in which stormy space is
hidden are still on Instagram so you're
referring to about the body garden no oh
the bland I'm referring to was put into
the morning toasters group by toaster it
was a screenshot of a John Doe tweet
that had this news story and then it was
quoted with the blind item that said
basically that there are legitimate
threats of someone trying to kidnap
stormy webster and so that's why Kylie
deleted all the photos so like I
allegedly I follow a lot of celebrities
and a lot of bloggers and like
I'm just so shocked that there's not
more people who don't put their kids on
social media show shot I'm so shocked
that there's not more people who don't
put their kids on social media like I've
thought about it a lot like I don't
think that I'm gonna be like up here
sharing all the time it's so scary to
make an Instagram no and like I don't
I'm just surprised like all these like
regular girls with like regular lives
putting their kids like Kylie is like
the security team of the president like
they'll be fine like all these regular
girls who like live in regular homes and
like are always putting pictures up of
their house and their kids like I could
come kidnap your baby like I know
exactly where you live not that I'm
going to but like I don't know I'm just
surprised that more people don't have
the sentiment and that they're not more
careful
yeah I feel like someone's gonna like
I'll have to learn the hard way the hard
way I'm like look I've already made the
guy already feel nervous about putting
Theo out there no but like I've made the
decision that God willing when I have
kids like I don't I'm not gonna be like
that and that blogger mom that's fair
also like it's a lot of work like I've
never seen the dells kid cuz she's smart
yeah no but like turning your baby up
and like bonnets and like taking
pictures like that's so dangerous makes
so much work to I love like bloggers who
like give birth and literally put a
picture up of their baby like the next
minute like that's crazy
yeah yeah to each their own though I'm
sure I just say everyone seems to be a
little bit more you might have all the
Kim feeling where at first like you're
not gonna show anything and then like
you get more comfortable with it and
you'll show your kids for sure but it's
easily I comfortable with it when you
literally have a staff whose job it is
to protect your baby yeah I agree
anyways those are the stories for the
day you are unbelievable thing Heidi
Klum never post pictures of her kids
thinking of someone normal um you're
unbelievably inform out and now we need
to unfortunately talk about the
Bachelorette oh wait cuz I watched I'll
say I haven't watched a first two
episodes but like I just decided to
watch a saint and let me just tell you I
had a great time watching because I got
so much done I answered like a hundred
emails I made premium content about the
bachelor so I it was it was good do you
understand Colton underwent now oh my
god is he not the bee's knees he's the
bee's knees and I just want to say him
and Rebecca couldn't be more wrong for
each other no totally but he needs to go
far so that one till either go to
paradise or about G The Bachelor and
then if he's a bachelor ascending snitch
yeah I have the same thing maybe our
brother-in-law I really like Becca but
she's incredibly boring of course but
the back is so ugly geez it's like I
just I'm so unimpressed by this whole
thing the two like the three or four
dates that we saw last night I'm really
worried about ABC like they're very low
budget that literal dungeon they had the
spa date in with no windows tiniest room
ever they couldn't even hire real people
like they had to beggars friends come
and massage each other like weirdness is
horrible then some seasons they got Amy
Schumer other seasons they had Ashton
and Mila this season they have Richard
Marx who the [ __ ] is that
and like in this little room like with a
piano and it's like write songs for one
another it was like the most awkward - I
love was truly works I I was thinking I
gotta think what I would write like
about Ben I was like and you love him
yeah it's just my idea of a terrible
time and then group date I know they
were laying it on so thick with that I
wrote my feelings once I don't know oh
my god like when people are going
through traumatic things it's like
IRA my dad a letter and he didn't answer
like okay now write that guy 11
sweet then on the list of lo budgetary
concerns they take all these guys to
like a dirt road to play [ __ ] no one
who's been to her high school you guys
okay then they couldn't even spring to
get the back of the jerseys with
people's names on it did you see they
were putting duct tape down and wrote
their own like where is the money going
then I guess the nothing the money is
just not coming in like he used to fry
he's like lining the Fleiss Meister's
caucus yeah like I was just beyond
concerned and then like I literally
picked my head up at nine o'clock a
halfway through the episode and I was
wondering kim jeong-hoon and i was like
I was so confused cuz like I really
wasn't paying attention because I'm sure
at one point they were like we interrupt
to the special report I don't think so
at least I wasn't watching an episode
I'm watching I'm like oh it's only one
hour this week thank God I turned off
the TV and then I saw these tweets I'm
like oh wait no it's just like a brief
interlude right so here's what you
missed the end of Chris's aide he got
the room I watched her up okay and then
we got we lost the last ten minutes
because of the interlude so I turn my TV
off at 9:59 but then I realized they
said they tweeted that they were gonna
play the whole episode oh well oh if
you're if you T vote it then right our
of course but what I don't know who got
it out no rose ceremony but this is so
[ __ ] sad clay the actual
Peyer injured his hand on the date yeah
oh he had to remove himself because yes
I country oh he left for good
yeah he was cute he was cute and I
thought I had him going so far I'm gonna
totally I was beyond confused about like
who everyone is and I know that's
because I missed the first trips okay
but the guy who fell off the bombs wrong
with you and I was thinking I was like
they always have an ambulance there's
always something that happens that makes
it like super dramatic and this one
looked real because it was finally over
there was lunch had I grab someone's
shirt like you thought that was crazy
like in bachelor in paradise like Evan
like got a nosebleed and like they bald
it in from the altitude then I saw blood
I'm like finally a real fight and I'm
like they didn't say what happened for
so long I was so confused and then it
was like he fell off the bed but they
didn't say top bunk but it had to know
he was hopping and then it made sense
like he probably really did get hurt but
I thought maybe he had like a seizure in
his sleep and fell off the bed okay the
Instagram model I don't never want him
to leave I told he's my favorite
character he's only interesting I'm a
Wilhemina model Jun about what that
means with myth face comes
professionality and it's this face I
actually think he's so funny and like
he's camille Grammer because he's very
nice-looking man he has a huge
vocabulary yeah and jumper dish is
chicken do you think that tinder
sponsored that sag man because I do um
no I don't but I hope for the bachelor
sake though they did but then I also
hope they go cuz where's the money going
that was so funny that was a lot of
swipes like I don't think he's as
horrible as everyone says I think he's
hilarious like he knows what we want to
say no and like no she's not wedding he
he is there's something about him that's
like really not bothering me which is
crazy cuz always like the thirst monster
is the most bothersome a crystal right
and I find him to be so funny and like
honestly I'm finding David to be
annoying when he was like I get me to
chicken when he was saying that stuff
like what place is this now pensive like
he was being an [ __ ] yeah actually
model boy was handling and I stopped
making eggs who meets a ex like that I
know he was doing it wrong that's what
they're trying to do it's just like I'm
so funny someone put in one of the
toasters groups like I'm like I'm a
moment of appreciation for Becca's
wardrobe the season that she's like
killing it oh my god that toaster got
roasted like I'm like
got the bachelor treatment like an all
for press she looked amazing on Jimmy
Kimmel like she did I think a little
filler like she really she's working it
lets Becca but it's not coming through
on the season and that the wardrobes
arse not doing it for me
no the Wardrobe is is very some of the
best wardrobe was um Jojo Emily Maynard
and Jojo yeah Emily Maynard it's was
better but yeah um yeah but JoJo's was
very like timely yeah like she wore like
current self portably Manor season time
Naima lassic yes exactly
um it's actually really nice and I think
I know who wins
but it's really nice watching The
Bachelor being like so uninvested I
don't even think wins the only reason
why I'm invested and I need to stop
doing this is because I have a bracket
and like I just hate to lose so it's the
only reason why I care about who gets
out but next season I'm not doing a
bracket because like I don't need this
stress in my life who do you think
buttons just like go like that I don't
know I forget his name but I know that
it starts with a certain letter okay oh
right we're in the same room we had this
conversation okay
and the stuff about Coulson into yeah
like that was crazy and also like I very
much appreciate them breaking down the
fourth wall and being like Becca might
have not been the best red Tia might
have been and like it was so awkward for
Tia when Becca was like you think he's
here cuz he thought you were gonna be
Bachelorette and obviously and he's like
yeah I thought it was gonna be
Bachelorette - until you got dumped on
camera and that's why Tia hate sorry
because if not for our ego infection but
she would have been that triad and like
there's no doubt in my mind no shred of
a doubt that Tia I mean that Colton
Colton came for Tia but here's what's
not so Colton reach out to Tia before
re-season started airing so he might
have just seen that she was announced on
the cast he had no clue how far she was
gonna go or it might be the Bachelorette
he just made me thought she was kids so
they started talking she he told her
immediately that he was auditioning for
the show - it was super interesting
which girls they decided to bring I mean
they had to earn the episode with Becca
Martinez but I like to see Caroline
Looney and I like to see see em I love
to see Caroline I like to see CN and I
just I will never get on the taxidermy
train I was just gonna say and they come
and I loved here but like I just really
don't like that she's a mom in this
ramen like now her name is being like
dragged through the money's like that
other woman when it's like no she was I
think all those girls are really friends
but I don't think Tia's like it part of
that crew but they obviously brought her
because of a drama and then like we got
screwed because we didn't see Colton on
the football team right that was so what
the [ __ ] what
[ __ ] and why couldn't he go on both
dates because no one goes on both group
dates right in the beginning when it's
just a hodgepodge of God it's like I
hate these first like five episodes
because I don't know who the hell anyone
is but like us not getting to see Colton
in football pants or like what it's cool
isn't gonna take off a shirt I don't
know but it's gonna be a great day
I know I'm really excited I hope there's
like a hot date there is a date later on
when he's on a boat one-on-one perfect
Becca
making out mating suits the works and
I'm just so excited about it even though
the Nutri brother-in-law's then let's
start talking about Arie like they must
oh my god they must I thought after they
did the smell oh you didn't watch last
week she went on a date and they smashed
all of this stuff from my season that
like men something about her so why
would she broke up with her on TVs of
their proposal playing it was a horrible
they Lil Jon is scream singing in the
background like live is horrible no and
I saw it like that was gonna be it like
they were putting Arie to bed finally
but no everything is well when Ari did
this honestly like I'm so like
unimpressed with Becca like I just think
she's not she's not nearly perfect and
exactly what I thought about her is
exactly the problem I had with her her
personality's not big enough she's not
interesting and I've shot funny enough
like she's literally like a doll and
they tell her what to say she must be
reading off of a teleprompter yeah I
mean it is a dream of course she's doing
a really good job of teleprompter
reading and maybe when she comes off the
show like she could take Megan Kelly
spot yes she's being an actress yeah
what else we have to cut up everyone is
an actress it's so crazy Real Housewives
of New York that makes me feel like
anyone can be an actor it's like anyone
can be an actress right I go acting it's
just such a crazy profession no like I
say this all the time I act literally
every day yeah like I'm having a good
time like I don't want to go home you
know like hi how are you I don't care
okay Real Housewives of New York we
watch drunkenly in Nashville so like I
have to remember but all I remember is
that everyone's bullying definitely and
I'm not here for and I'm not here for it
but the greatest thing that happened to
Bethenny was Luann's arrest you guys
it's taking some of the heat off of her
some of that footage of LuAnn in the
back of the car like I cannot get over
tinsy really put it into perspective for
me because Tinsley was like I got a
misdemeanor charge and LuAnn has floor
felonies
she got about she just got a bunch of
them dropped like riesling I just I want
I'm it's now watching
back it's like how could this not have
happened this was unavoidable like she
had to crash and burn but like I just
want this chapter to be closed for her
and I want her to start fresh bitumen
we're also watching old episodes of her
Honi while we were getting ready for the
show and LuAnn was a completely
different like she's like through it
just so nasty like so above it on like
to see how far she's come since then
like I just I want her to keep moving
forward I'm she is I think top two
favorite Housewives I really I'm on her
team I'm rooting for her and having seen
now like it's a year later than what
we're actually watching flick I know
she's in a better place and these shows
are like really doing well for her and
like that she's hitting it on the road
so I'm just I'm so happy you guys should
go on tour together I know is that a
possibility I hope so
also something that I remembered is Lady
Gaga's twitter handle is counted it's
not because of countess LuAnn it's
because that she played a countess on
American Horror Story but she's also
obsessed with the countess she might
have played that on American Horror
Story because of the cast I just wanted
to say okay
oh no it's definitely connected for sure
and I mean because everything is
connected to the Housewives also Ramona
coming out the skincare line called
ageless by Ramona I will be purchasing
into a because the work I need to look
like her we you said you know who her
plastic surgeon is the girl okay
the reason Real Housewives of New York
started and why Ramona's on it because
Ramona's crisis surgeon who she goes to
once a week was approached by production
first they're like we want you on the
show she was like no I would never do it
cuz I come to private but I have a bunch
of clients who I know would love it and
she recommended Ramona and there were
Mona Bregman but all the girls okay we
need to see her aha Botox for once and
for all yeah because like I want to look
like Ramona when I'm 61 me too she looks
incredible and good for her for
launching a skin Carolina okay and I
want to talk about the rock the what's
called Nutcracker
okay now cracker date yeah because now
there's mixed messaging the way that it
was promoted on the show was that
Dorinda and her costume designer
searched all over town and got it for
her but then I'm reading on the blogs
that actually Dorinda gave Bethenny her
costume designer and the costume
designer and Bethenny like looked all
over town Bethenny paid for it like so
what did you and by the way and Bethenny
still was so grateful crying sitting on
the floor scream also what we didn't see
because we didn't watch the end of the F
so but they do to flashback to the
Berkshires whenever in the show's heard
the photo sure that she got it and she
says I'm so grateful thank you so much
but so at the end of the day German just
still didn't even get it for Bethany
Bethany got up herself but Dorinda gave
her the vehicle to fight it look great
but for the vehicle she had the proper
amount of gratitude right so it's just
like this being the cause of everyone's
like rice with Bethany I'm like I'm not
care for it I'm team Bethany always a
forever
also when Bethany and Carol sit down
one-on-one it was like I can't watch
these two people fight because it's
[ __ ] painful one thing it's like I
texted you saying I miss you Karen
that's not what happened obsessed with
this I'm gonna need the screenshots of
what happened because I can't listen to
these two anymore and what Bethany was
like you're debating me like you're
you're taking everything I say and like
ripping it apart and yeah I didn't come
here to watch a debate I came here to
watch the Housewives so if you could
just show me a screenshot
especially when I wipe dry housewife's
fighting like this happening aren't tell
me about like texts and phones is so
stupid because at the end of the day I'm
sure they're both right they're both
just like older and like don't know how
to use phones and like I'm sure one of
them did ten site attacks and one of
them didn't see it like I don't fault
either one of them for that part and
that happen in row houses of Orange
County - like they just like it when
Tamara didn't include the context like
it was really actually an age gap thing
because like Lydia's young enough we're
like writing something in Tamra's like
she's a phone so like the phone stuff is
a little stupid and we can't see it so
like stop talking about the texting yeah
and it's like when we're doing a pug you
talk about the Oh or just show
screenshots of the taxi and you know
Bethany has a receipt of course she's
been doing this long enough but also her
skinny girl Jean line no I was thinking
like it's weird that it's called skinny
girl and then it's like inclusive girl
sizes yeah I'm sure they struggled with
the branding on that one right and I
just have had to skim over it yeah
unless they're like slimming actually so
bad cuz like they're supposed to make
you mm-hmm just something to think about
um what happened on southern charm we're
seeing everyone from southern charm
tonight oh my god I'm saying they're
filming the reunion as we speak what do
you think's happening Thomas is not on
the seating I thought it's like a little
annoying because like I'm glad your
emailing Kate I'm glad he's being
punished for being a Pradesh yes young
man but I'm a same time old man but at
the same time like we need answers we
need answers he needs to be held
accountable get teddy Mellencamp on the
stand it's all I'm saying Jessica
McCallister the best is when the Real
Housewives print out their email
my messages for the reunion and like
behind the pillow they've literally like
Xeroxes of phones and so funny that is
so many southern charm I just caught up
um pretty much a decent episode it seems
like things are gonna get really crazy
and there's a lot of rumors that Ashley
and Thomas are broken up but they're so
they're unjustified watching the show I
don't see how they even made it to like
when they came on our show like they are
falling apart at the seams she liked all
of her she all her crazy is coming out
and like he is not into it he's making
she's making his life so difficult and
he's not even into her like there's no
pro of them even being together I can't
believe we hosted them like I've such a
pit about it I do too but like we were
just trying to be open-minded and you
know what we were played a fool no so
Shep invited me and Jax to dinner
tonight and I'm just like I'm I'm kind
of nervous like for who's gonna be there
Thomas and Ashley are not gonna be there
now okay because do you know me
yes is she gonna be there yes okay good
and also I'm like so excited to meet
Chelsea no I was just gonna say I'm
actually really excited to meet Austin
I'm excited to meet us and to tell them
that their members each other and like
just watching the season it's like yeah
technically she was holding on to his
arm and like if I saw a girl doing that
to Zach he would never be able to speak
to her again but it's like but you're
getting in the way of true love but so
Victoria whatever you're in the wrong
cuz true love will prevail right you're
never gonna win because you're not meant
for each other so it's like
it's a silly a Miss for each other
famous couple scratch history
I'm gonna go Chelsea an option I'm gonna
go as I'm Shakespeare
yeah Shakespeare Romeo and Juliet what's
that uh I don't know that seems a little
basic for Josie yeah but they were in
high school
oh no but she definitely went is like
Emma Macbeth
yeah and Hamlet I'm more than his mom
okay guys the guards do you think about
Hamlet it's like I remember reading it
in high school hold on bless you
I remember reading it in high school and
like don't let the symbolism of books
like was always going about my head like
they were talking about a stick and like
was meant to be a penis I just thought
it was like a stick you know what I mean
you know and you know what it was a
stick because if it's not just tell us
totally it's like this is all about
surface layer me too and like the like
the under the surface like meaningly I
never understood so when we were reading
Hamlet and like we got to the point
where it was like he's nuts the [ __ ] his
mom like I remember the teacher was like
and then
the kind of like understand what that
means it's what's called an Oedipus
complex yeah he said that and then I was
like no I'm like he just loves his mom
and some girl raised her hand and she
was like he like wants [ __ ] his mom and
I was like why I'm like you're
disgusting and then he was I guess
that's right that's correct Chelsea and
I was like that's crazy but it totally
went over my head but I also hate it
when like you analyze it so much like in
class and it's like Shakespeare never
said that like no and I said well I have
a hard time believing like if these
writers who like spent their whole time
writing books like wanted to say
something like they wouldn't just say it
no no there's definitely some like
subtlety but like when you start getting
like way too deep like no no no that's
just you like that's not Shakespeare
there needs to be a line that's Joran
and like and you know how much we've
read between the lines
you know what like it's a book that like
had the most reading between the lines
weathering Heights static I don't even
know what happened it lived with some
trees and like the trees were always
singing like a tracer weather yeah and
like the way the movement of the trees
was like reflective of the movement of
the love story like just please like
trees blow cuz there's wind no and also
like a who's that author Oscar Wilde
what's that book that you all have to
read mmm anyone yes just give me a
second okay portrait of Dorian Gray
yes oh my god that was so crazy at least
that made sense there was a picture of
door and also my man dad wait and note
was it like was he the picture or like
was it a figment of was it really a man
or was it always like a figment of this
portrait oh my god like like it's just
[ __ ] like Dynasty exactly you guys
if you're not watching dynasty you ain't
live in but that's a good thing was like
you could legit make anything up and
like an essay and it would be right
because like how do you know what the
author was and no that's the best part
yeah how do we know what the author
meant like maybe really how am I did
just like his mom yeah you know a sickos
had to say that he once to have sex with
her right I'm T's whole thing is
[ __ ] and that's why I'm I would
never go back to school and then if I
could Lion King is based off of Hamlet
but Simba didn't want to have sex with
his mom this was a children's movie
that's disgusting
yeah oh so we need to talk about sex in
the city for a second because we just
wanted to be watching it yeah we've been
relaxing it every night in Nashville
watching before going to sleep and
unfortunately we got caught in the worst
season of all time which is season five
the Jack Berger sad where she has short
curly hair and the sufferable and I just
I can't
and I went and like justice for everyone
else in the cast we're having to put up
with her like no truly and I know you
don't just like justice for Miranda okay
you know what like I'm happy for you and
Miranda like I am so T I'm so torn
between who I love more Charlotte or Kat
if they are in our Super Friends we
would like Miranda but we can't get past
it because she's so like ugly and has
like the sad life with like the ugliest
guy okay you know what bothers me this
is what I've said also she's running for
governor and her slogan is vote homo not
cuomo and she's got my vote
that's a it's very hilarious but I need
to do more research than that fine
um this is what bothers me and this is
this is not cool so okay Moran is a
lawyer yep
she has a husband a child and a dog and
oh and they don't they can't afford an
apartment in Manhattan they have to move
to Brooklyn harry goldenblatt is a
lawyer
she has a wife now two daughters and
dogs who had babies but they can afford
apartment on Park Avenue so I don't did
they move to Brooklyn because of the
money because they heard they needed
space and they couldn't get that space
in New York that's a really good point
but why also Charlotte and Moran is a
partner because okay fine but Charlotte
had money and Charlotte had money
because she's like a rich like Upper
East Side gal she she like what does she
have money does matter she's a pedigree
like she's family money she's never had
to worry about money so between the two
of them they could afford to say he owns
a bar and owns he's a bartender no but I
don't consider Charlotte a money imagine
like me I do I think they're both single
income homes and why can't they both
need the same is definitely single
income but Charlotte has a trust fund
they never spoke on it but she totally
does I don't I don't think so or else
she wouldn't have been like I don't and
by the way they didn't have to move
because she was given an apartment right
but you sell to paint like apartments
don't just pay for themselves like
they're [ __ ] expensive but when you
get them from someone else they do pay
for themselves but then you know how he
can afford that her living in an old
building I'm Park Avenue like maybe you
even have a mortgage like but she
renovated the house when she was with
Trey so she'd not pay for that either
right no that I understand I'm just
saying like why Miranda is a big-time
magazine editor lawyer and she has to
move to Brooklyn
even though Harry has the same you know
that's a very interesting point but also
you know women get paid 77 cents on the
dollar and back in the day it was
probably worse maybe should they get
similar jobs but she was obably making
like three and but
we that's all subtlety a subtle nuance
in the show is that like she had mood or
Clinique 77 cents on the dollar so I
remember Harry's firm is called like
Bernstein and goldenblatt it's his firm
but and she worked for a while and then
she made partner and by the way when you
make partner in a firm it's not what you
think you have to pay what to make but
you feel like 250 grand to make partner
yeah so it's like it's not even that
great what that's horrible no I know
also just a few horrible things about
Carrie it's just one mention please when
she shamed Charlotte into giving her
money even though big who's made of
money offered her $30,000 to buy her
apartment which also makes no sense she
was living in a rent-controlled
apartment on the Upper East Side for
$750 a month makes no [ __ ] sense um
big versus Aidan you asked someone asked
you this I'm max I'm Q&A what did you
say I wasn't watching I feel torn about
it because separately like
Aidan is hot and like I think he might
even be better than big just because I
keep with such a family guy such a
normal guy like he didn't play these
stupid games you know wait till he was a
hundred to get married but Carrie is the
worst and you know what so was big
they're perfect for each other
so if you're asking me who do I like
better as a person and who do I think is
more of a catch I would say Aidan but if
you ask me who's better for Carrie it's
big because they're both psychos who
don't want kids honestly she's not good
enough for either of them yeah and right
now I'm watching the Russian episodes
and I'm actually even the way they're
also perfect for Jane Alexander
Petrovsky however he gave us you are
call me yes and words a dime internally
grateful soon and too at one point he
like really put Carrie in her place when
she's like being such a wiener about
like Samantha and her cancer and
Petrovsky's like I had a friend who had
cancer she died and Isaac like they have
a whole fight about it and then put
traps he's like you're being a child
like this is the real world yeah thank
you like she's a 40 year old child she
is the [ __ ] worst and then also like
him taking her to Paris like that's the
life she's always wanted and then she
got there and didn't stop to play she's
also a terrible friend doesn't listen to
anybody makes terrible choices and he's
always talking about herself when her
friends have actually interesting things
going on I couldn't agree more in like
any time she's like having a
conversation with someone she always
said brings it back to her she's like a
one-upper I'm around it's like and then
Steve did this she's like oh my god me
too
and then bit like [ __ ] shut up listen
to someone else no it's
frustrating but I think we've narrowed
out in the worst episode of and I made
you watch it yeah which one was a season
5 episode 1 where she is quote dating
New York yeah if you just want to
understand why we feel the way we do
watch out
but up until season 5 she was actually
fine like she wasn't my favorite
character but like I could watch see
there's just like nuances of things that
she do it does that like she needs to
get slapped and Petrovski did it give me
that water bottle this is what she
didn't know and also it's like up until
season five she was just doing her thing
and then all the things that are
annoying about her like production told
her to do more like okay so what's
putting your lip on her teeth like
normal oh yeah
like what she's writing I couldn't help
but wonder okay wait
oh so normal person drinks water like
this Carrie Bradshaw drinks water like
this I couldn't help but wonder she's so
my getting away it mad at this where she
drinks her martini yeah like in front of
the mirror she's so extra like so
annoying
it's like she's such and the way she
talks to like big when she like comes
over in her candy striper uniform
she's so I went big wakes up when big
wakes up and she's like being mean good
because he's like over he said things
last night he takes back and yeah and
she was like no one else could decipher
the ship except me I was like [ __ ] I
saw that from a mile away you know when
she's just like any time she gets
embarrassed like when Berger when
they're sitting outside the Hamptons
party and then he like randomly runs
away on his bike I like post a jacket
out from underneath her like if she
falls like that's the best thing ever
any time she gets like embarrassed or
like sad like it's like on the one hand
I don't like Berger but on the other
hand like I was so excited to my episode
where he dumped her on the one on the
one hand burger as a human being seems
like the worst boyfriend of all time
but another hand like his character was
so pertinent because someone needed to
put that [ __ ] in her place okay wait
Oh so Finland said we have to ID younger
which we do I just yes I know but I'm
I'm in the middle of catching up because
I watched your first season and then we
never got to it
season three after like fads aside that
was so crazy that was so crazy I did not
see that happening no but it's like it's
a little stupid like I really want
everyone to find out and then apparently
I haven't seen season five yet but
Margo's telling me that like Sutton
Foster looked so old that like it's not
even possible anymore that anyone could
ever believe she's 27 but it's like if
you believe this person your friend like
my friend say my friend is my friends
she's funny fix like and she starts
looking older like I wouldn't be like oh
my god she's 40 years right like what
have you found that Rebecca like had a
kid and lived in New Jersey like
obviously I'd be like cool that's can we
need her and I'm just like over this
Charles [ __ ] oh my god wait the best
part of Sex in the City
it's like the part where Harry and
Charlotte break up because she said
something so mean to him and then they
both go to the singles event at the at
the shul and someone says Charlotte up
with their son and their son is played
by Charles and he's like literally the
perfect man for Charlotte two seasons
yeah um well that's all she wrote I'm so
good I feel like I had a lot to get off
my chest like when I woke up I had like
this burden on me because I was like
it's so much to say and now he said it
and we could like go through the rest of
the week just doing like regular shows
it feels great um but thank you guys so
much for loving supporting and following
the morning toast if you don't know what
the toast is if you literally just like
stumbled upon this on YouTube the
morning shows are daily live morning
show for Millennials if you don't care
about NATO or like Kim jong-un or like
summit and you just wanna talk about the
Kardashians about joined Real Housewives
the morning toast is the morning show
for you we're live every day at 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook on YouTube
and then we're also available in the
podcast app if you're not available to
watch slides and if you're a podcaster
but the commute so make sure you like us
on all those platforms girl with no job
your host Claudia a shrine check the
ashtray at Jackie Oh problem it's been
an absolute pleasure hanging out with
you this morning I'm tired I'm going to
take a nap bye
[Music]